en este vídeo hablaremos sobre cómo
encontrar las unidades para la constante
de velocidad acá hay dos cosas que
debemos saber antes de empezar una es
que la constante de velocidad que si
tiene unidades
esto no siempre se aplica a las
constantes en química pero acá si tiene
unidades y la otra cosa que debemos
saber es que las unidades de la
constante de velocidad k dependen de la
ley de velocidad
velocidad entonces vamos a usar esto
usemos la ley de velocidad para deducir
las unidades de acá y esto es muy
práctico porque así no tenemos que
memorizar cuáles son las unidades de acá
para las reacciones de cada uno de los
diferentes órdenes en este caso vamos a
enfocarnos en las tres leyes de
velocidad más comunes que vemos en las
clases de química es decir vamos a
hablar de reacciones de orden cero de
primer orden
y de segundo orden
orden
y vamos a deducir las unidades unidades
ok entonces primero veamos una reacción
de orden 0 las reacciones de orden 0
tienen una ley de velocidad que se ve
así la velocidad es igual acá por la
concentración del reactivo a elevada a
la cero y recordemos que cualquier cosa
elevada a la cero es igual a 1 así que
en este caso la velocidad es igual a la
constante de velocidad acá y las
unidades de la velocidad siempre son las
mismas siempre son molar por segundo y
también podemos ver a las unidades como
números es decir si tenemos el signo de
igual las unidades deben de ser las
mismas para que coincida entonces en
este caso como la velocidad es igual acá
eso significa que acá debe de estar en
molar por segundo entonces esto nos dice
que las unidades para una reacción de
orden 0 son molar por segundo y podemos
usar la misma idea para conocer las
unidades
para una reacción de primer y segundo
orden entonces para una reacción de
primer orden
la ley de velocidad es velocidad es
igual a la constante de velocidad k por
la concentración de nuestro reactivo
elevado a la primera potencia y ya
sabemos que las unidades de la velocidad
son molar por segundo y las unidades de
la concentración siempre serán molar así
que ya podemos deducir que las unidades
de acá por molar debe ser igual a molar
entre segundo por lo tanto como ya
tenemos molar en ambos lados no tenemos
que preocuparnos por eso pero nos
faltaría uno entre segundo así que las
unidades de acá son uno entre segundos
otra forma en la que podemos intentar
conocer las unidades si es que no se
sienten muy cómodos con lo que hicimos
sería reordenando esta ley de velocidad
vamos a ver si dejamos acá de un lado y
todo lo demás lo pasamos al otro nos
queda que acá es igual a la velocidad
entre la concentración de a lo que hice
fue simplemente dividir ambos lados de
la ecuación entre la concentración de a
y como sabemos que las unidades en ambos
lados de la igualdad deben de ser las
mismas entonces podemos conocer las
unidades de acá al dividir las unidades
de la velocidad entre las unidades de la
concentración entonces para la velocidad
tenemos molar por segundo entre la
concentración que es molar así molar
se cancela y nos queda 1 entre segundo
esa es una forma más directa de
encontrar las unidades de acá pero la
idea es la misma podemos tratar a las
unidades de la misma forma en que
tratamos a los números y solo hay que
asegurarnos de que coincidan en ambos
lados de la igualdad ahora el último
ejemplo que veremos es para las
reacciones de segundo orden
entonces las reacciones de segundo orden
tienen una ley de velocidad donde la
velocidad es igual a la constante de
velocidad acá por la concentración del
reactivo al cuadrado entonces de un lado
tenemos molar entre segundo para la
velocidad y del otro lado como ahora
tenemos la concentración al cuadrado
entonces tenemos molar al cuadrado así
que molar al cuadrado por algo debe de
ser igual a molar por segundo entonces
necesitamos agregar ese 1 entre segundo
en las unidades de acá porque debemos
asegurarnos de que cuando multipliquemos
esto nos quedarán segundos abajo y
también necesitamos cancelar una de las
unidades
concentración entonces vamos a poner
molar también en el denominador ok así
las unidades de cas para una reacción de
segundo orden son 1 / molar por segundo
estos son los tres casos más comunes que
podemos encontrar en una clase de
química y muchas veces puede que
tengamos reacciones que no son ni de
orden cero ni de primer o segundo orden
pero si eso pasa siempre pueden usar la
ley de velocidad para encontrar las
unidades de la constante de velocidad k